からす
[Music]
kiedy mój angielski St coraz lepszy
nastarała we mnie ogromna chęć żeby
rozmawiać ludźmi pamiętam Taki dzień
kiedy moi przyjaciele wyciągęli mnie Z
domU
Byard
usłośę ale kż głoś noł powiział
powiedziałem ja angielski
odwracąłowę zobaczył pewn blondę oraz
chłopaka obok niej który później
został example  i Italian är den 4 Juli
Bara en en varm sommardag Medan i USA
betyder det Öl vänner grillfest
nationell Stol och mycket mer detta Var
riktigt Berik för mitt Liv och inget av
det skulle jag hänt det inte varit för
Stepen Kings Bok som jag köpte och
kämpade  att läsa för jag tände min önsk
att förbättra
min ass from a youth hostel had
two friends of mine in Prague and there were
three Parisian women sitting right next to
us and we started chatting and
they were very surprised by my French
and thanks to that and also thanks to that in
fact we started to discuss and
one of these girls in fact she
became my friend for 5 years I
started to understand the similarities and
the differences between France  and
Italy I understood that in fact in
France you should not cut the salad
when you eat when you eat at the table
uh but I understood that the French
are rightly proud of their bread of
their pastry of of  their food uh
but above all I fell in love
with a person and I understood what it
means to express it in a foreign language
nadadis teria acontecido eu tivesse
desistio de francês
escola quer contar ESS histrias sou par
falar sobre feit que aprendi  francês o
ingls escola eh o que eu quero que tu
guardes ouinte
queingm
inter
conierer de
depr rich with every language that I
know thanks for listening bye